- I pin a lot of hair tutorials,
but I'm not very good
at doing my own hair.
- I have very thick, wavy hair.
- It's pretty thick, I have a lotta hair.
- It's frizzy all over, kinda poofy.
- It's not too thin, not too thick,
it's just, like, right in the middle.
(mid-tempo electronic music)
- [Voiceover] Two minute updo tutorial.
Two minutes? Looks like
you took, like, all day.
- Put the hair elastic on like a crown.
- Then I, like, try to
look real Coachella,
but I'm gonna probably end up looking
like I have a mushroom on my head.
- There's no, like, words, this is hard.
- And twist it up, then
keep tucking your hair in.
- [Voiceover] This is
not good for short hair.
- It doesn't even accept it.
It's like the rubberband
doesn't even get my hair.
- (laughing) Oh my God, this is a mess.
- I don't think this looks good,
like, even on the model that's doing it.
I mean, I think I did it, but I hate it.
- Okay, if I put, if I
keep putting one side
then the other one falls...(sighs)
- Well, here you have it.
(instrumental electronic music)
- [Voiceover] Now we're
gonna do an easy hair bow.
(laughing) Emphasis on the easy.
- Oh God, this is the worst.
I don't get extensions for this?
This is (bleep) up.
- It doesn't really say what
to do, it just has photos.
- (laughing) I look like a warrior.
- (laughing) But the hair
should have gone in different.
- Then you quickly grab a piece of hair,
as fast as you can,
and then you fasten it.
- I don't know, they're
not telling me anything.
I'm just making educated guesses
but feeling like I'm nailing it.
- I have testicles on my head.
- Everyone has really cool, like,
easy thrown up hair and then I try it
and I look like a demonized Mickey Mouse.
(mid-tempo electronic music)
- [Voiceover] Straightened braid waves.
I'm gonna braid my entire head,
but this girl only has, like,
four braids in her hair
that are, like, this big.
(laughing) This is really
gonna take me awhile.
- Here goes nothin'.
I have so much hair, this
girl has no hair at all.
- La-di-da, gotta braid my
hair for a good 20 minutes.
- I have transformed
myself into Snoop Dogg.
- They're just so great right now.
- I guess I straighten them.
- Here we go! (laughs)
(laughing) Another 20 (bleep) minutes.
- [Voiceover] You could poop at
least 10 times in that period.
This better look good!
- What's better? This? Or this?
(whispering) This one.
- Herbal Essence commercial.
- Look at it! I look like when
Simba got out of the water.
- [Voiceover] It looks frizzy and weird.
- Ah, yeah.
Oh, yeah! Oh yeah.
(instrumental electronic music)
- Pinterest is so cool
and I go on it everyday
and I just feel like a little girl
whose hopes and dreams
are shattered daily.
- If you have short hair there's really
not much you can do unless the person is
actually, like, a short
hair-specific Pinterester.
- Maybe someone that is
better at this kinda stuff
would have better luck than I just had.
- Be you, you know, like, pay
attention to these tutorials,
but, like, do it the way
you would wanna do it.
(mid-tempo hip hop music)